او ما الذي يقدمه هذا المؤتمر بعد الاع-
اللقاءات السابقه التي شهدتها الاشهر
الماضيه في لوغانو برلين ما الجديد في
مؤتمر باريس يعني هذا المؤتمر همم اريد
منه ان ينظم على مرحلتين المرحله الاولى
التي شاهدنا افتتاحها الان وهي مخصصه
لتنظيم مساله مساعدات لمواجهه الحاله
الطارئ معنى لمساعده الاوكرانيين على
تجاوز صعوبات بشكل خاص فصل الشتاء من خلال
توفير همم
المواد اللازمه توفير الطاقه الحاجات
اللازمه حتى هناك معلومات عن تبرع فرنسا
او تقديم همم محولات كهربائيه ل 63
مولد كهربائي اوكرانيا وايضا محولات
وتنسيق هذه المساعدات وهذا ما اعلن عنه
الرئيس الفرنسي عن ايجاد اليه
شكرا اليه باريس بالتنسيق مع اليهوديه
موجوده اصلا انها لمواجهه الاجور الطارئه
في هذا التوقيت
والمرحله الثانيه المؤتمر ستعقد بعد ظهر
اليوم وستكون على همم سعيد ثنائي اكثر منه
دولي بين فرنسا واوكرانيا هو ل
همم ترتيب
مرحله اعاده الاعمار
وتموضع الشركات الفرنسيه تحديدا نحن طب
سمعت شركه سترك في هذا المؤتمر مع
الاوكرانيين لمرحله اعاده الاعمار طبعا
القراءه همم الاولى لهذا همم لهذه
المبادره هو ان رئيس فرنسي ارانب ان ياخذ
خطوه استطباقيه في وقت ان كل الاهتمام
الدولي وخاصه الغرب عمليا الامريكي يركز
على مساله السلاح نعم الاستمرار همم يعني
دعم الاوكرانيين بالسلاح لمواجهه الروس
والاستمرار الحرب يقول انا ان مرحله اعاده
الاعمار يجب التفكير فيها ويمكن بدا من
هنا الاوكرانيين يطلب هذا الامر منذ الان
طبعا اللافت في هذا المؤتمر هناك 47 دوله
حاضرا رئيس فرنسي اكرر اكثر من مره انها
ليست فقط هو الغربيه صحيح لكن الحضور
الابراج واربي حتى الولايات المتحده اشارت
الى غياب الصين لكن حتى الولايات المتحده
ممثله بنائب وزير شؤون الطاقه بمعنى ليس
الرئيسيه ليس وزير خارجيه ليس نائبه رئيس
ليست بمعنى ان في النتيجه
مباشره الان لكن مساله اعاده الاعمار نعرف
انها عندما توحي تضع الحرب او زارها الدول
التي ستلعب دور اساسي على الارجح يعني همم
ستكون الولايات المتحده ربما تركيا ال-
همم حتى الصين بشكل من الاشكال هي غير
حاضر على مستوى عالي في هذا المؤتمر هي
محاوله لاتخاذ خطوه السباقيه للتموضع في
رساله اعاده الاعمار اضافه الى الرد على
حاجيات متطلبات عاجله ومباشره
للاوكرانيين من خلال هذه الانيه التي تم
الاعلان عنها هذا الصباح وبانتظار بعد
الظهر ايضا على المستوى الثنائي مساله همم
امور ملموسه في ما يتعلق بتنسيق وتموضع
شركات فرنسيه مع شركات اوكرانيا شكرا لك
وسيم